the next morning the co-host will
replace damn
who were these two john k and rachel
burden hosted the show
they got fired all came together and
like you know the
islamists are trying to stop our freedom
and this is our we stand for
bs you guys are double standard
hypocritical
slub of the gullion [ __ ] animus
pigeon-hearted
weasels yes you heard that yes with some
tape with mama the job
i constructed that together and i
believe it's well deserved
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use a discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamu brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are wearing
inshallah
i came across the video and i was like
wow
like you've you've literally reached the
pinnacle of hypocrisy and double
standards i want to react to this video
where
two bbc presenters are fired
let's find out why why they fight let's
let's find out mom and sister i'm gonna
go straight into it because this is
hilarious
yeah this is hilarious
is not up to standard size uh government
interview
um measurement so i think it's just a
little bit small but uh
that's your department really
the picture of the queen there as well
though in the westminster office i'm
assuming
these jokes cost bbc breakfast today
host
naga manchetti and charlie state their
careers in the bbc can you believe that
let's carry on let's carry on can we do
that the minister laughed at the joke
during the live interview but later
tweeted
we're always proud to fly the union flat
out blah blah it's a symbol of liberty
and freedom
that binds the whole nation together
listen if we go against your what the
hell just happened they lost their job
just because they made that pathetic
distinction
weird this little joke about the size of
the union flag
yeah and the queen's picture being there
okay manchette apologized for her
twitter
uh from her twitter account saying i
like
i like tweets today that were offensive
in nature about the use of the british
flag as a backdrop in the government
interview this morning i have since
removed this life they do not represent
the views of me or the bbc i apologize
for any
offense taken british media called for
the dismissal of the coast that these
co-hosts
for joking about national symbols joking
not insulting
joking yeah the telegraph said the bbc
must stop employing those who despise
their own country
independence said love the flag and the
queen or move to another country
conservative mp tells the public okay
interesting some like telegraph writer
simon heffer
inserted race into the debate oh he
might go racing today here start
appointing people of similar talent who
happen to be white
middle asian who do not despise their
country okay so
making a joke about flag me despise the
country the next morning the co-host
will replace
damn who are these two john k
and rachel burden hosted the show they
got fired
they got fired guys can you believe that
now hold on a second now hold on hold on
a second
uh well i don't know where to start here
and this is how you know this is
this notion that the far right had as
well we saw the freedom
speech the freedom event and tommy
robinson's when miami hijab were nearly
getting killed
because we said can a muslim speak they
said no no that's because
they're a muslim and that interview is
coming out with kailyn robertson
inshallah
uh very soon where we also react to a
video of her unedited footage
of tommy punching drunk people as usual
because that's only people you can knock
down
um immigrant yeah and we're gonna watch
that what really happened behind the
scenes i did a reaction
with kaden robertson check that out on
also the full interviews coming on
byline tv
um brother sisters let me tell you
something here this whole notion of
freedom of speech is
bs yeah liberty we're liberating
liberation of the nations whoa
yeah it's nonsense yeah it's nothing
but a false flag brothers and sisters
okay
it's so bizarre that insulting the
prophet peace be upon him
it's okay there's no problem insult him
it's freedom of speech
you can't stop us if you're stopping us
you're against freedom of speed you
don't like this
leave our country okay making a
joke about a damn flab i've got nothing
against the flag
for it or against it it's just a damn
flag in france if you insult the flag
you get
arrested you get a fine you
you they made a little joke a damn
joke about a flag the size of a flag
the size of the joke was this little and
the size of the flag was a bit bigger
and that joke cost them their job and
you want to come and tell me about
freedom of speech
when they all came together and like you
know the islamists are trying to stop
our freedom and this is our we stand for
bs you guys are double standard
hypocritical
slub of the gullion posted anonymous
pigeon-hearted
weasels yes you heard that yes with some
tape remember the job i constructed that
together and i believe
it's well deserved it's so annoying
broken sisters to see the double
standards
one rule for one another for another it
is disgusting
and this is the notion that the far
right are pushing freedom must be
you do not believe in damn freedom of
speech do not come to me with some
freedom of speech
you don't believe in it it is nothing
but a tool for you to spread further
hate towards muslims or other
nations or other people whoever you like
and then you have these dooms yeah these
multans
yeah that's what we're going to call it
from now on hakim said you know may
allah
yeah come in talking about freedom of
speech there's one guy flipping harry
potter
looking like clown who's um it's simping
over
some girl he's also another mustard uh
yeah
and he's he's gonna find out that she
actually has a boyfriend and i think
that's one of the reasons she left islam
yeah she found love by living in many
ways so you've got this clown here maybe
you can see him on the screen yeah
he's trying to basically abandon me from
australia yeah he's
trying his best but i can't wait to go
to australia and see a kangaroo take a
picture with a kangaroo and have some
coconut water and send a picture to you
okay you bloody cowards
that's what you guys are you don't
believe in freedom of speech we don't
believe in counsel culture
you see how they go against their own
principles
they will go against their own
principles like the quraish did i'm
going to end
this not broken sisters like the prophet
peace be upon him told us they go
against
their own principles and is bound to
because when truth comes
falsehood perishes and is bound to
perish when is the is the messenger of
allah or is islam
yeah mock in seoul swear freedom of
speech why stopping the freedom of
speech
if i was to insult the flag i'm telling
you my life would be in danger i'm
literally telling you they would look
for me and execute me
i'll be done i'll be absolute islamist
jihadi
going against our flag you see we told
you
look at the double standards and this
double standard has been shown and
people are seeing right through you guys
be the bbc be the fire right whoever it
may be so brothers and sisters and i'm
not sure what i'm trying to say to you
guys inshallah
is that the double standards double
standards and the oppression these
people
applied in the treaty of hodeidah when
the the prophet peace be upon him the
companies were going to hajj
and they were stopped by the muslims and
said what you're not coming home this
year you're going to come next year
number two if anybody comes to islam
from uh the mushriks they're basically
any muslims run to you yeah
they run to you or they become a muslim
and run to you you send them back to us
so you'll persecute them yeah
and if anybody in medina leaves islam
no harm will touch them and they would
come back you have to send them back to
us
here look at how unjust eyes but guess
what allah sent
to a revelation and allah says indeed we
have granted you a great victory
sometimes we see things and promises
we're like you know what
that's so unfair and just don't worry
have your trust in
allah because it's a great victory
that's been given let them oppress us
let them see their double standards and
hypocrisy when they come and talk to
talk to us about freedom of speech but
you can't even insult a flag let's
get insult you shouldn't i believe no
one should insult it
but you can't even joke about it i'm
gonna leave that that broken sisters
and it's clear that these people do not
give a damn about it
and all of this far right the enemies of
islam and these mort
yeah this clown wannabe flipping harry
potter
white guy want to be flipping a little
weasel
yeah little boy uh perverted little
clown he already doesn't talk about his
bloody private parts what desperate guy
you know please be finding my bloody
girlfriend or something you know
subhanallah
anyways guys until next time i just
wanted to highlight that shared with
your friends and family and let the
whole world see the hypocrisy till next
time